like for example recently with the whole
netflix thing 1st season watch oh yeah I
didn't say much of anything to anybody
until the contract was signed but even
now to this moment I'm like I won't
believe it until it's actually on
streaming on my laptop or TV you know
sorry so how did that happen how to do
get labs on Netflix well it's it's not
there yet but I was approached by the
new media film festival they have a
distribution arm no and they're getting
shows together to put on Netflix Amazon
iTunes and also some hotel rooms and
such there's like a whole list art scene
units big it's a big list of vendors and
they they approached me before Christmas
and was like we would like to get laughs
on there and and so I made sure that it
was everything's copacetic with 2020
productions and and then we signed a
contract so we're we're set to be on
there but we don't have a set date so
that's one of those things it's like
yeah well we'll see hopefully yeah I
hope I mean we have a contract yeah say
contracts yeah that's pretty no okay
yeah so yeah I mean this little show
that I just thought up my head while I
was running on the track and then shot
on my iPhone nothing cool ya never know
where things go mm-hmm
you